miles de simpatizantes se agolparon en
la carretera mientras el féretro de la
reina llegaba al palacio de holyrood una
procesión lenta y sombría mientras
soldados vestidos con faldas escocesas
llevan el ataúd a la sala del trono
dentro de la residencia oficial de la
monarca en escocia poniendo fin a lo que
fue un día emotivo para los dolientes
dedicó toda su vida a servirnos como
nación y simplemente sentí que no había
ningún otro lugar en el que quisiera
estar que aquí para presentar mis
últimos respetos la corona sobre el
féretro de la reina fue elaborada con
flores de su residencia de balmoral
donde comenzó su viaje de 6 horas hasta
la capital escocesa tras reposar en el
palacio de holyrood el féretro de la
reina será llevado al lunes hasta la
catedral de san gil- donde la familia
real se reunirá para un servicio
religioso
algunos a museos otros vítores se leyó
la proclamación que nombraba a rey a
carlos desde el balcón de la catedral
mientras la multitud esperaba la llegada
de la reina que es una madre y una
abuela para todos nosotros
ha sido una constante en mi vida era la
reina cuando yo nací y siempre he estado
ahí creo que me va a costar mucho
adaptarme a que ella no esté aquí mismo
yo tras 24 horas en la catedral es angie
la féretro será trasladado en avión
desde edimburgo a londres el martes la
reina llegará al palacio de buckingham
antes de ser velada en westminster donde
el público podrá presentar sus respetos
antes de su funeral el 19 de septiembre